dieses Gericht kostet nur 1 Euro und es
schmeckt nach so viel mehr weil all
diese Zutaten wenn man es runterrechnet
nur 1 € Kosten fangen wir an indem wir
ein bisschen schnibbeln unsere
Frühlingszwiebel leicht angewinkelt
einfach runterschneiden ist nicht nur
günstig sondern geht auch verdammt
schnell eine Karotte eine Zwiebel und
all das geben jetzt in unsere Wokpfanne
die schon schön heiß Knoblauch hinterher
und auf höchster Stufe bisschen Action
machen alles frisch angebraten kurz
rausgenommen damit wir jetzt den Reis in
der Pfanne machen können der sollte am
besten vom Vortag sein was auch gut geht
ist dieser Kochbeutel Reis weil der hat
die gleiche Charakteristik rein die
Pfanne aufteilen unbedingt in Bewegung
halten so dass jedes Korn geröstet wird
jetzt machen wir ein bisschen Platz in
der Pfanne für unser Ei und schlagen das
hier an den Rand wenn das Ei drin ist
direkt kaputt machen bisschen verkühlen
und hier an der Seite einfach ein
bisschen vor sich hinbacken lassen wenn
es sich schon langsam setzt dann mischen
wir es jetzt mit dem Reis würzen und
Salzen tun wir das ganze mit Sojasauce
und Austernsoße und auch hier wieder
alles gut verbinden jetzt kriegt es die
typische Farbe und jetzt können wir
wieder das Gemüse dazu dann noch schön
Farbe ist knackig und fertig ist unser
eckfright